and this uh is the kill wow I brought
the kelp here about a week and a half
ago okay
um and it's been setting here to dry but
you can smell it it smells a little bit
like the ocean it does it does oh this
is awesome I just love it they're so
cool just like open the middle of a farm
right yeah
what we see is that when we put the kelp
down the grass just starts to grow so
much better it's kind of phenomenal wow
this was 2100 pounds so that's about a
ton this is what a ton of kelp looks
like how much area are you applying the
kelp to maybe half an acre more or less
so a ton per half acre you really
couldn't get enough kelp you couldn't
get enough kelp and one of the big
questions is like how can we extend them
the benefit of Kelvin is there some way
to like super dry it and make something
like a kelp pellet right hey you could
just spread across your Fields almost
like even mulch with it absolutely and
so these are the questions that we're
currently exploring on this farm so that
we can pull nutrients out of the near
shore system where it's causing a lot of
pollution exactly and bring those
nutrients and this carbon up here into
the grasslands where it's going to
simulate production the idea is that
this kelp is drawing carbon out of the
ocean
it's the craziest thing yeah yeah I just
love it
some carbon dioxide that ends up in the
atmosphere is absorbed by the oceans and
as Dr joth Davis mentioned excess carbon
causes the sea water to have increased
acidity
kelp in the ocean much like plants on
land draw carbon dioxide in and take it
out of their surroundings
but as Eli points out when that kelp is
transferred to land the soil stores the
carbon and can benefit from the
seaweed's nutrients
in the ocean
nitrogen and carbon are an issue and so
then the kelp takes it up like a little
vehicle and then you just take it here
and put it in the soil we're benefiting
the Marine system and then we can start
to benefit the terrestrial system that's
honestly so freaking cool I think it's
super exciting to think about how this
could be a piece of what we do to
address some of the big challenges with
climate change
Eli is one of those people with
contagious enthusiasm really passionate
about the work but also cares about the
environment but what I also love about
this is like it didn't come in any kind
of packaging and you sourced it locally
so this is stored carbon and we can take
this stored carbon put it out on
Grassland or pastures and those
grasslands can sequester more carbon
right putting it down in the soil and
storing it you know I grew up around a
lot of traditional agricultural farms
and so bringing something like this
something that's exciting into the
market something that's new as a farmer
it's like we're spending money to get
carbon-rich materials and here it is
just hanging out in the ocean and you're
putting it into your soil and then
you're growing some really nice grass
but then what are you doing with that
grass it does require some grazers so we
should go look at some of the pastures
oh oh yeah should we go check them out
[Music]
thank you